en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta ocasión iniciamos hablando de
materia oscura los científicos estiman
que las galaxias planetas y demás
cuerpos que vemos en el universo
constituyen sólo un 5% del total el 95%
restante estaría compuesto por materia
oscura como su nombre lo dice se trata
de materia que no emite ningún tipo de
radiación electromagnética por lo que no
la podemos ver no es absorbida por
materiales ni tampoco es reflejada ahora
aunque se defiende que no estaríamos en
el universo sin la existencia de esa
materia invisible se trata de algo que
hasta el momento no se ha podido
comprobar y son muchas las iniciativas
que buscan cambiar esa realidad pues en
dakota del sur en eeuu funciona el que
se considera el detector más sensible de
materia oscura creado hasta la fecha se
encuentra a 1600 metros de profundidad
en una antigua mina de oro el
experimento fue bautizado luxe plin y
está dentro del centro de investigación
subterránea de sanford donde se ubica el
corazón de este aparato un tanque
gigante llamado criostato
este es el crio estado interno un
criostato es como un termo entonces el
xenón es muy frío y debemos mantenerlo
frío
entonces necesitamos un recipiente de
metal grande en el que podamos poner 10
toneladas de un líquido
para demostrar la existencia de materia
oscura los expertos buscan capturar
partículas dentro de un tanque con xenón
un líquido que reduce en gran medida la
radiación del fondo de los tanques de
titanio protegiendo al detector cuando
las partículas se estrellan contra un
núcleo de xenón algo similar al choque
entre dos bolas de billar la existencia
de la materia oscura sería revelada por
un destello de luz que sería captado por
la cámara de proyección temporal
para buscar este tipo muy raro de
interacción el trabajo número uno es
deshacerse primero de todas las fuentes
ordinarias de radiación que desviarían
el experimento
estamos buscando partículas exóticas que
vienen del espacio exterior pasando a
través de la tierra construimos un
instrumento que creemos que será
sensible para ver estas partículas y si
las vemos va a revolucionar lo que
sabemos sobre de dónde vino el universo
porque se ve de la manera que lo hace y
que constituye el universo en una escala
muy pequeña
incluso más pequeña que la atómica
ordenada recordemos que la materia
oscura se considera uno de los grandes
misterios del universo y esta
experimento con el que sería el detector
más sensible creado hasta el momento
tiene una posibilidad de éxito de entre
el 10 y el 50 por ciento parece una
probabilidad baja pero para los
investigadores se trata de una incógnita
tan grande que vale la pena intentarlo
saber qué es la materia oscura nos dirá
cómo se formó el universo en los
primeros días porque evolucionó de la
manera en que lo hizo y por qué se ve
cómo se ve hoy cuando miramos hacia el
cielo hoy vemos estos vastos cúmulos de
galaxias y luego vemos estos vacíos
gigantes que están libres de galaxias no
hay eventos en absoluto saber qué es la
materia oscura proporcionará una
explicación de por qué el universo tiene
este tipo de estructura similar a una
burbuja que vemos hoy y cambiamos de
tema y vamos a francia porque allí fue
desarrollado una especie de arnés
diseñado para personas con vista
limitado nula se llama byd wang y es un
artefacto que funciona con inteligencia
artificial actuando como un copiloto por
lo que le indica a quien lo usa por
dónde ir para evitar o seguir una ruta
según sus responsables se trata de la
misma tecnología que mantiene a los
vehículos autónomos en su camino les
permiten no chocar contra las
estructuras que se encuentran
bay pitt es un dispositivo de navegación
creado para personas ciegas es un
pequeño arnés que se lleva en los
hombros tiene algunas cámaras 3d
incorporadas hace algo similar a lo que
haya un vehículo automático pero a
escala peatonal detectamos obstáculos
coches peatones pasos de peatones y
dependiendo del contexto pintamos el
ambiente para quedarnos con la
información más importante y avisar al
usuario con sonidos 3d o una nota
musical para cada tipo de objetos
alrededor del usuario reproducía
directamente los auriculares que llevan
puestos como lo decía uno de sus
creadores back to danés genera sonidos
3d intuitivos para advertir al usuario
sobre la ubicación de cualquier cosa con
la que pueda chocar esas señales suenan
mediante un par de auriculares de
conducción o sea que dejan los oídos
libres para escuchar normalmente
y finalizamos en china donde un equipo
de expertos de la universidad de sichuan
desarrolló peces robots que como en
microplásticos y que algún día podrían
ayudar a limpiar la contaminación de
nuestros océanos son suaves al tacto
miden 1,3 centímetros y ya son capaces
de absorber micro plásticos en aguas
poco profundas
el principal propósito de nuestro
trabajo es detectar micro plásticos en
la superficie del agua pero queremos
aplicarlo luego quisiéramos ir más
profundo e idealmente poder detectar la
composición los micro plásticos marinos
y cargar la información por ahora
trabajamos en la recolección es un robot
de recolección que puede ser usado
repetidamente
los expertos exponen que la estructura
de los micro plásticos a través
sustancias nocivas como los metales
pesados lo que amplifica su toxicidad
por lo que son mucho más dañinos que los
plásticos ordinarios pues este pez robot
negro es irradiado mediante luz si otros
peces lo comen accidentalmente puede
digerirse sin daño ya que está hecho de
poliuretano es capaz de absorber
contaminantes
solo si se daña así finalizamos este
espacio a ustedes les agradecemos su
sintonía continúen con nosotros en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]